dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here due to
popular demand here is the new deepmind
paper on wavenet wavenet is a
text-to-speech algorithm that takes a
sentence as an input and gives us audio
footage of these words being uttered by
a person of our choice let's listen to
some results from the original algorithm
note that these are all synthesized by
the AI the blue lagoon is a 1980
American romance an adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser
the blue lagoon is a 1980 American
romance an adventure film directed by
Randal Kleiser
aspects of the sublime in English poetry
and painting 1770 to 1850 aspects of the
sublime in English poetry and painting
1770 to 1850 all this requires is some
training data from this person's voice
typically ten to thirty hours and a ton
of computational power the computational
power part is especially of interest
because we have to produce over sixteen
to twenty four thousand samples for each
second of continuous audio footage and
unfortunately as you can see here these
new samples are generated one by one and
since today's graphics cards are highly
parallel this means that it is a waste
to get them to have one compute unit
that does all the work while the others
are sitting there twiddling their thumbs
we need to make this more parallel
somehow so the solution is simple
instead of one we can just simply make
more samples in parallel no no no no no
it doesn't work like that
and the reason for this is that speech
is not like random noise it is highly
coherent where the new samples are
highly dependent on the previous ones we
can only create one new sample at a time
so how can we create the new waveform in
one go
using these many compute units in
parallel this new wavenet variant starts
out from white noise and applies changes
to it over time to morph it into the
output speech waveform the changes take
place in parallel over the entirety of
the signal so that's a good sign
it works by creating a reference network
that is slow but correct let's call this
the teacher Network and the new
algorithm arises as a student network
which tries to mimic what the teacher
does but the student tries to be more
efficient at that this has a similar
vibe to generative adversarial networks
where we have two networks one is
actively trying to fool the other one
while this other one tries to better
distinguish fake inputs from real ones
however it is fundamentally different
because of the fact that the student
does not try to fool the teacher but
mimic it who are being more efficient
and this yields a blistering fast
version of wavenet that is over a
thousand times faster than its
predecessor it is not real time it is 20
times faster than real time and you know
what the best part is usually there are
heavy trade-offs for this but this time
the validation section of the paper
reveals that there is no perceived
difference in the outputs from the
original algorithm
kaalia so where can we try it well it is
already deployed online in Google
assistant in multiple English and
Japanese voices so as you see I was
wrong I said that a few papers down the
line it will definitely be done in real
time apparently with this new work it is
not a few papers down the line it is one
and it is not a bit faster but a
thousand times faster things are getting
out of hand real quick and I mean this
in the best possible way what a time to
be alive this is one incredible and
highly inspiring work make sure to have
a look at the paper perfect training for
the mind as always it is available in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]